the former crown prince of jordan hamza
bin hussein says he's been placed
under house arrest in a video message
the king's half-brother
sharply criticized jordanian leaders but
he denied being part of an alleged coup
plot
authorities have arrested several other
high-level officials
for what they describe as security
reasons
jordan's crown prince hansa bin hussein
on his wedding day in 2004
an embrace from his half-brother king
abdullah
[Music]
six months later the king would strip
hamza of his title of crown
prince and give it to his own son
instead
but hamza remained popular in jordan
close to tribal leaders
and seen as in touch with ordinary
people he now says that's why he's been
targeted
in a video sent to the bbc hamza says he
is under house arrest
after being warned that he got too close
to critics of the king
he says he is not part of any conspiracy
but he does
openly condemn jordan's leaders this
country has become stymied in corruption
in nepotism and in this rule
state tv earlier announced that hamza
had been asked to stop activities
targeting quote security and stability
it said security agencies arrested
multiple former top officials
as reports swirled of a plot to unseat
the king
the army denies that the former crown
prince himself is under arrest
but alarm bells are ringing for jordan's
allies which see it as a key bastion of
stability
in a volatile region
recent protests against coronavirus
restrictions fanned concerns
that stability could be wavering after
years of austerity
but king abdullah has the backing of
regional leaders
and powerful friends the u.s and saudi
arabia are among those who have
expressed support
jordan's security forces say
investigations into prince hamza
are ongoing let's bring in rana schweiz
she's an iman based journalist and also
the author of
voices of jordan thank you so much for
being on our program
now uh jordanian authorities are denying
prince hamsa's claims that he's been
placed under house arrest but they do
confirm a wave of other high-level
arrests
what can we make of all this
so the lack of information and a video
released
by the former conference of jordan
prince hamza
he confirmed in details first of all
that he's virtually under
house arrest and all communication was
cut off
he claims and his security taken away
from him and his family
important to note the prince released a
video in arabic as well directly
talking to jordanians and saying pretty
much the same things he said
in in the english video as well
all this took place last night in jordan
where we were under curfew uh due to the
corona virus and so it's interesting to
note the timing of of the press
statements
and the video as well um and
it's been hard to get information in
this environment to be honest with you
government sources have released here of
course a statement
saying that people were detained
including a member of the royal family
member
sharif hassan and also a former royal
envoy to saudi arabia
so we're getting you know continuously
some conflicting
uh information and we were told earlier
today that
a statement would be released before
noon but uh
as you can see nothing has come out
today well we should mention this is a
quite unusual
set of developments for jordan i mean
these types of high-level political
arrests are very rare
in the country also for a senior
member of the ruling party to express
such criticism of the government
is very rare what does this tell us
about the stability in jordan at the
moment
yeah it's this video is really and the
words
also that were said are rare if not
unprecedented in jordan for the west and
neighboring
the countries you know jordan is
normally a stable arab kingdom
that has been a staunch ally of of
countries in europe and the us
particularly when it comes to
counter-terrorism cooperation
in the middle east of course it borders
israel
um the israeli occupied west bank syria
and iraq
um so it is
really a rare uh kind of
tensions that we have not really seen
before at the forefront
uh hamza was named crown prince of
course in 99
and then king abdullah transferred the
title to his son
in 2004
prince hamsa is usually photographed
meeting uh with tribal figures and
is known really to be popular and has a
a very sort of uncanny resemblance to
his father king hussein journalist
rhonda schweiz
imam we thank you so much for your
reporting
thank you
you